I like McDonald's but their breakfast
has just never appealed to me I've never
had an American McDonald's before when I
was growing up I was a Burger King kid
then when I got older I started loving
chick-fil-a then chick-fil-a start
hating gay people and now I don't eat
fast food I think eating McDonald's once
every 16 years isn't going to be
terrible
I don't know french fries are involved
how could it not be delicious that's
lazy it man looks like someone trampled
on it wait I've never had a burrito for
breakfast I didn't realize that was the
thing what's in this nope I think that's
good okay I did not want to sew all that
it tastes like actual eggs this is why
I've avoided it all this time because I
mean I knew it would be delicious it's
like a little too slimy and look I feel
like that's even like a hint of a
vegetable doesn't look like me that's
kind of gray but I'll eat it anyway
she's it tastes good
ooh a sausage McGriddle duh sue
McDonald's coming out it looks so gross
in like sad oh it has an M on it that's
fancy what's in it I'll have like
injected syrup into the pancake and it
raisins
that's really with it like smashes you
over the head with syrup genius I don't
think I would ever order this but I
would eat it alright so I've heard of a
McMuffin this is like something people
are like way into they always thought it
was like a word for something sexual
this one has the nutritional facts on it
just gonna skip that it's pretty
delicious yeah
the cheese is like yellow glue sauce has
that like plastic look to it you know
and just too much bread I'm just eating
bread take that off and see if that's
better
but now I have to look at what I'm
eating which is kind of a nightmare this
one's not that bad it tastes like a
Dementor kiss to the flavor out of this
so it's not that good either where's
that burrito I'm on that burrito back oh
man this looks like an airplane
breakfast this Sarah is so intoxicating
I've never like eaten syrup before so
never had syrup I'm
gonna put it all on because I think
that's what American people would do I
mean there's been syrup' around me I
just haven't eaten no I didn't vote but
I know that you know syrup and with a
pancakes are not bad it definitely days
like a fan gay kiss of bread look good I
mean I would put Vegemite on this cache
Brown I'll give it a 10 a 10 out of 10
on grease it looks like a big Chicken
McNugget that's the best thing we've had
some fun I don't think I've had a hash
brown before but it's good I like it I
don't really like tater tops so I'm just
gonna say I'm go ahead and hate me I
don't think I would want to eat
McDonald's breakfast again that was
nothing else around yeah I'd have it am
I gonna eat it again yeah probably give
me 16 years
you